la mobilisation autour des prévenus et
témoins importants devant le tribunal
qu'au mois de décembre peut-être parce
que seulement deux d'entre eux
attendaient la réponse du tribunal quant
à leur demande d'exception de nullité de
procédure après avoir jugé les
accusations portées à leur égard dans la
citation du procureur imprécise voire un
fondé une demande que le tribunal
correctionnel à tout bonnement rejeté ce
jeudi sans préciser son argumentaire
j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans une
espèce de spirale d'une affaire qu'on
veut faire durer sur laquelle pour moi
je continue à penser qu'il y avait pas
lieu que l'on soit poursuivi alors
aujourd'hui on nous annonce que nous
nunité de procédure ne sont pas retenues
bon j'attends de lire précisément les
attendus du jugement pour décider de ce
que sera ma défense dans l'avenir très
honnêtement voir que les garanties qui
sont dans la loi notamment des garanties
extrêmement strictes de possédures soit
considérée aujourd'hui par le tribunal
comme ayant été parfaitement remplie je
suis plus étonné je suis assez
stupéfaite
également accusé pour diffamation par le
ministre brissortefeu est venu en
soutien à ses camarades elle n'a pas
fait le choix de remettre en cause la
procédure et attend à présent avec
impatience que le débat sur le fond de
la faire s'ouvre lors du procès enfin
que les questions de fond soit posées
parce que on l'a dit plein de fois mais
je vais le redire bon il y a eu les 6 de
peau il y a eu les journalistes du béry
repu maintenant il y a nous il y en a eu
d'autres avant il y en aura encore après
donc ça serait temps qu'il y a un vrai
débat de fond qui s'installe et oui moi
je moi la décision me satisfait mais de
prévenus concernés ont à présent 10
jours pour faire appel de cette décision
s'il ne remette pas en cause une
nouvelle fois la procédure le procès de
ce que l'on nomme les quatre de Tours se
tiendra le 17 février prochain